british prime minister boris johnson and
kenyan
president uhuru kenyatta are co-hosting
a global summit on education
they're calling on international leaders
to help rebuild education systems
in hard-hit countries a particular focus
will be
on the handful of regions countries in
the sahel region
of africa which are considered fragile
conflict states
last year 5 000 schools were forced to
close because of
threat of violence exploitation and
kidnapping there
the situation is particularly acute in
nigeria nigeria has a kidnapping crisis
on its hands
this year alone there have been more
than 150 of these incidents in the north
of the country
with a significant number of victims
seized from schools
just this morning at about six
i received a phone call that they have
entitled school kidnappers and all our
children are back
including my daughter inside who goes
down here
we confirm that they are old park the
attackers are known locally as
bandits armed gangs littered across
parts of northern nigeria
with no specific ideology they often
take their victims into remote areas
like forests
where they cannot be easily located the
exact number of incidents is hard to
know
but even the reported cases of school
kidnappings make for a long
sobering list
the situation is so desperate that
according to un estimates
more than a thousand schools are
currently closed across northern nigeria
the insecurity has forced nearly 400 000
students to stay home for their own
safety
according to amnesty international that
leaves the education of an entire
generation
at risk of being lost
well for more on that i'm now joined by
julia gillard she's the former prime
minister of australia now the head of
the global partnership
for education welcome to dw you're
trying to raise money for better
education but we just saw in our report
that hundreds of schools
in the region are closed due to
insecurity attacks kidnappings
this is a problem that money can't solve
is it
it certainly is a major problem and
resources are always needed
but more than resources which is why at
the global partnership for education we
conceive of ourselves
as a partnership that tries to bring
people together
to solve problems as well as a global
fund to mobilize
new resources so these situations are
complex
there is never one easy snap your finger
solution
it is about working with the government
working with communities
trying to change attitudes resources do
assist with that but certainly a spirit
of partnership and joint endeavor is
needed
the other big crisis is of course the
coronavirus pandemic unicef says that
170 million children globally
school had their schools closed for a
year what are the consequences
we are desperately concerned that the
covert crisis could push the world
backwards on education we came into this
crisis with around 250 million children
of school age who weren't in school and
hundreds of millions more receiving a
substandard education
but we were making progress we were
improving things
as schools have closed around the world
we have been
truly concerned that like in the ebola
health
epidemic when schools closed that when
they reopened the most at-risk
children would not return particularly
the girls
so informed by that ebola experience
during this pandemic
gpe has mobilized to be there with
countries to try and maintain
educational continuity and to try and
ensure school systems are ready to bring
every child back into education but more
needs to be done which is why we're here
in london today
at a summit co-hosted by the prime
minister of the uk
and the president of kenya we've put out
an appeal to the world to ask people to
raise their hands and to contribute new
resources so we can keep
building rather than being pushed
backwards by covert but you also said
that once the pandemic
is over we shouldn't just go back to
school as we know it but
but we have to fundamentally reform
education
what do you want to see changed yes we
are in the business of transforming
education
and i think what that looks like is
every child
getting access no matter where they live
no matter how remote
know the characteristics of that child
every boy
every girl not having disability or
ethnicity
exclude children from school and then
when they're in school that they get a
full cycle of schooling
a year of before school and then 12
years of schooling
and it is at a quality standard which
enables them to be ready for life
we know we live in a world of constant
change of huge changes
and getting those foundational skills
during your school years
is the key to unlocking everything else
in life and enabling you to navigate
whatever the future might throw at you
well with all the other problems the
world is facing
uh right now which is on the news every
day would you agree that
leaders world leaders are taking the
education crisis not seriously enough
i think world leaders have got a bulging
in trace there's no doubt about that
this has been a
stressful time for all of the global
community
and a stressful time for those who are
leading during this age
but i do believe that whether it's in
germany or many other parts of the world
are that there is a recognition that
education is the profound
change agent and a focus on girls
education
and there's been a great spirit of
partnership as we've got ready for
today's event
particularly putting a focus on girls
education
julia there from the global partnership
for education
from london thank you very much thank
you